what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video I made a video
the other day where I listed several of
the characters that I believe will
survive the game of Thrones so today I'm
gonna continue that list by naming a
handful of other characters that will
survive this deadly game in my opinion
before I get into my predictions I just
have to thank all of you first because
today I'm actually celebrating the
one-year anniversary of this channel one
year ago on October 17 2016 that's when
I sat down and finally decided I was
going to create my own game of Thrones
channel I was actually introduced to the
game of Thrones television series a
little bit later than most people and
when I think back to when I first
started watching this great show I wish
I had gave it a chance sooner because I
had no idea how fascinating it would be
and what kind of an impact it would have
on me and most likely everyone watching
this video I personally became addicted
almost immediately and I fully immersed
myself into this world an online
community shortly after that where an
entire new outlook when the series began
when I first started watching this
series for the first time I had no idea
there was an entire community online
that had already been talking about this
series in books for years and even
decades on some older message boards but
I really have to thank the person who
started the whole R + L equals j theory
because that was the first one I had
ever heard about and that was the first
theory that interested me enough to get
online and look further into it for
myself and that's where I stumbled
across people making youtube videos
about that theory and literally every
other Theory you can think of and trust
me when you think you have a new theory
that you created on your own you can
usually find it already out there
somewhere posted on some random blog but
after watching dozens of other videos
and reading hundreds of other articles I
fell in love with the online community
and I said to myself you know what now
it's time to make my own channel and
start talking about the things that
interest me and when I made my channel
one year ago today I could have never
imagined it would have turned into what
it is now when I made my first video I
was wondering if anybody would ever be
able to even find it let alone watch
them and like them but now one year
later and Here I am with over 200,000
subscribers and over 50 million views my
videos have
watched over 50 million times and that
just blows my mind so thank you to
everyone that I supported me over this
past year because it truly does mean a
lot to me and that's the main reason why
I continued to make videos as much as I
do it really does feel good when
somebody leaves a comment saying that
they love your video or they can't wait
to see your next one so I appreciate
that and hopefully you will continue to
watch for the next year but now let's
get into today's topic like I said at
the beginning of this video I want to
continue the list of characters that I
believe will survive the entire series
if you did not see part 1 I will put the
link down in the description of this
video that way you can go see which
other characters I think will make it
out of this game alive but today I want
to start the list off with everyone's
favorite night the onion nights are Devo
Seaworth let's be honest here who
doesn't love this character you would
have to be one cold-hearted person to
hate Davos and it's that love for this
character that kind of makes me nervous
because if Davos died it would be
absolutely heartbreaking I think he's
one of the most genuine characters in
this series and although he's not the
best fighter I do think he will survive
the Great War I think Davos kind of
falls in line with the cripples bastards
and broken things which is one of the
reasons why I think he will live I
actually made a video several months ago
before season 7 even started and in that
video was about the cripples bastards
and broken things and how I thought they
would be the characters to survive and
make the world a better place in the
future these were the characters that
were getting [ __ ] on their entire lives
and these were the type of characters
that no one would have ever thought they
would do anything special but in the end
I truly believe they will be the
difference makers and actually they
already have Tyrion Lannister once said
that he had a soft spot in his heart for
cripples bastards and broken things but
I believe it's actually george RR martin
who has the soft spot in his heart for
these characters which is why they ended
up being some of the most beloved and
important characters in this series i
actually wouldn't be surprised if george
martin felt this way himself when he was
growing up he was probably never looked
at as one of the cool kids in school
because he was a nerd who loves science
fiction and fantasy and stuff like that
but he has created a story that has made
characters like himself very important
to the story
just like with Samwell tar
Sam was always overweight and getting
picked on even by his father who wanted
him dead but now Sam has became a very
important player when it comes to saving
the entire realm no one is ever gonna
look at Sam like he's the star
quarterback leading the men onto the
battlefield with a sword in his hand
kind of like John but he knows when to
stay in his lane which is hitting the
books just like tyrion tyrion also said
am i needs books like a sword needs a
whetstone and what did Sam do before he
left the Citadel he snatched all kinds
of books and documents that he knew what
helped them during the long night and
just like he has done on several
occasions he will find the information
they need it's gonna be just as
important as a great swordsman is on the
battlefield this is what I love about
this story and show because almost every
character has a role to play no matter
how big or small you are I'm sure people
thought brain stark would be stuck in
his bed for the rest of his life as a
[ __ ] but look at how important his
character has become now an even Tyrion
was only looked at as the despicable imp
who was drinking and whoring his way
through life but he has now risen to
hand of the Queen a title that he had to
earn and I think Davos falls right in
line with these type of characters Davos
was an illiterate smuggler that was
missing half of his fingers on one hand
but now he has pretty much hand of the
king for the second time
Davos might not be the kind of character
that's gonna kill a white Walker but
it's his Council that's just as crucial
I think his knack for survival will
continue and he will be another
character that is perfect for helping
restore some sort of order after the
wars are over Podrick Payne is another
character that I believe will survive
this series - Podrick has been a squire
for years that no one really gave a [ __ ]
about besides Tyrion and now Brienne he
could barely defend himself but he saved
Tyrians life during the Battle of
Blackwater Bay but now he's spending all
of his time with one of the greatest
fighters in the Seven Kingdoms they have
shown us Podrick training with Brienne
all multiple occasions and I believe
they have been showing us this for a
reason
Podrick might not look like he's getting
better because Bryan is still kicking
his ass but a bet Podrick is becoming a
good swordsman and when the time comes I
think he will step up and do something
people wouldn't expect
I believe Podrick will end up killing a
white Walker or he will end up saving
someone else's
during the Great War you have to assume
Podrick has been training this entire
time but they can't show us that in
every single episode but now that John
has all the dragon class he needs
everyone in Winterfell will be able to
have a white Walker killing weapon if
they need it I expect her to be a means
to an end since they continue to show us
training scenes with Podrick and he will
defend himself quite well when it's time
and this will help keep him alive one of
the great joys have to survive the
series as well I believe someone from
each major house will survive to further
the line but this one is a little harder
to pin down because I can make a case
for either Yara or Theon unfortunately
for Theon he can no longer reproduce and
he's gonna have to put his life on the
line once again in order to save his
sister so Theon is the one most likely
to die but Yura is already a prisoner of
one of the biggest psychopaths in this
show Joran Greyjoy she could potentially
die at any moment but I strongly believe
you're on Greyjoy will die and Theon
should play some kind of role in that
but Fionan may die in the process so if
I have to pick which of the Greyjoy's
will live I'm gonna have to gamble and
say you're a Greyjoy we'll be the one to
live even though she currently has the
worst odds against her because your aunt
could kill her before Theon even gets
there but I'm gonna stick with this for
now
Theon will die saving his sister but
fian will be remembered as someone who
didn't die as a coward and if your ax
ever has a son she can name him Theon
Greyjoy I'm pretty sure Lyanna Mormont
will survive also I don't really have a
theory about why I think she will live
either I just don't see them killing off
this character right now
I think Lyanna Mormont has become too
much of a fan favorite at this point and
I know that doesn't mean a character is
safe just because they are a fan
favorite because they have killed many
of them off before but as of right now
Lyanna Mormont does feel like she's a
safe bet she's a strong character from a
Great Northern house although it is a
smaller house but she can further her
family name also and when this series
ends there needs to be some kind of hope
for the future you can't have all these
great houses go extinct by killing off
too many characters or the ending is
gonna be just bitter but this is just my
dumb opinion there are two more
characters I want to add on this list in
this video and
I'm gonna admit I'm taking an even
bigger gamble saying both of these
characters are gonna live because I
could easily see either one of them
having to sacrifice themselves in order
to end the great war but I want to go in
the opposite direction of some of the
bigger theories out there so I'm now
gonna go on record and say Jon Snow and
bran stark will live and I know some
people are probably gonna say I'm an
idiot for saying that but I now believe
they're both gonna live I started to
think to myself how are they gonna end
this series are they gonna allow John
and Daenerys to live or are they gonna
kill both of them off personally I think
one of them will live and one of them
will die now I know some people don't
believe Daenerys will die because this
show is all about feminism and Daenerys
is Danaan days favorite character and
yada yada yada
but I disagree Daenerys Targaryen will
die and Jon Snow will live
Daenerys said she was born to rule the
Seven Kingdoms and that's really all
she's wanted to do but in the end she
never will just like she saw in her
vision she will never touch the iron
thrown into snow that was falling on the
throne has always meant Jon Snow was the
rightful ruler in front of her Jon Snow
doesn't give two shits about being king
or sitting on the Iron Throne but in the
end he will be the rightful ruler of the
kingdoms but I believe he will
distribute the power amongst several
people with each Kingdom having its own
independence in the end Daenerys dragons
won't have even mattered because it's
not going to get her the throne in the
bastard that was looked down on was the
one born to rule the entire time and
when he is finally in position to do the
right thing with the power that he has
nearly every character we have come to
know will be dead I do believe the will
will be broken but Daenerys won't be
around to see it in place as she had
envisioned
Tyrion foreshadowed this during season
seven it's actually been foreshadowed
more than enough times for me to believe
that Daenerys is gonna die and I thought
for a long time that John would end up
sacrificing himself to save the realm
but I actually think he will live the
Lord of Light didn't bring him back just
to kill him again but hey what do I know
I do have more that I want to say about
this but it would take another ten
minutes for me to say it right so maybe
I'll save that for another video but I
feel the same way about bran stark now
- I think there is a very good chance we
could see the end of magic but I don't
necessarily believe that means brain has
to die there are some convincing
theories out there that say bran will
actually have to sacrifice himself to
the night king in order to stop him but
I disagree obviously it's not going to
be easy to kill the night king but I
don't think it's gonna take some kind of
sacrifice to achieve this bran might
lose his green sight after the night
king is defeated but I doubt it's gonna
cause him to die because of it but I
have to say I would not have made some
of these predictions just a few seasons
ago but the show now feels like it's
going in a different direction
even though Dan and Dave know how the
books are gonna end I don't think the
show is gonna end on the same note it's
probably gonna be very similar but
they're gonna have two entirely
different impacts on the community after
watching Season seven things don't feel
quite the same but I don't want to
ramble so I'll just end the video right
here feel free to leave your questions
thoughts or opinions down below in the
comments once again thank you all for
the support this past year because I
really do appreciate that especially to
all of you who stick around during the
long night when the show is off the air
you are the hardcore fans that I love
and I hope you all have a great day
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you